so a scientist writing in Psychology
Today has written an article and he's
saying that when we first is what he's
arguing he's saying when we first meet
aliens we may have to kill them in the
name of scientific progress that we can
dissect them and he wrote this article
and he published it on the Internet and
I've just read it just now and and
here's here's my point it's it's the
Internet the aliens can read this - so
you just announced to the aliens your
plans to kill them think about that now
I considering these you know these waves
go out into space that could be seen by
the aliens I would just like to make it
clear that I oppose the plan to kill
aliens so just just keep that in mind
to our future alien overlords when they
do come I am NOT I do not support this
all right today Friday is I think it's
gonna be my chance to go back through
the weekend and hit some of the stories
that I didn't get a chance to talk about
mainly because of the stupid debates but
there were several several interesting
items aside from dissecting space aliens
that I think are worth talking about and
we're gonna start with with this which
which surprisingly enough I didn't
discuss during the week and that is
Mario Lopez the cautionary tale of Mario
Lopez as you've no doubt heard by now
Lopez ended up in the left crosshairs
this week for and this is an outrage by
the way that has not subsided for him I
just I just read an article just
published I think last night on NBC News
blasting Mario Lopez so they're they're
not over it yet they're still very upset
the reason why they're upset is because
Lopez in an interview that I think was
actually back in June which only now for
whatever reason got everyone's attention
he made the extraordinary claim
extraordinary correct claim that that
three-year-olds are psychologically
incapable of choosing their own gender
so he now he was he was on the candice
owen show when he said this i want to
read what he actually said because it's
very important that he did stipulate
three-year-olds in what he said and it's
important for us to realize that when we
look at all the outrage and I mean so he
said look I've never wanted to tell
anyone how to parent their kids
obviously and I think if you come from a
place
love you really can't go wrong but at
this that's not true you can you can
still go wrong but at the same time my
God if you're three years old and you're
saying you're feeling a certain way or
you think you're a boy or girl or
whatever the case may be I just think
it's dangerous as a parent to make this
determination then well okay that you're
going to be a boy or girl
whatever the case may be okay and that's
that's all he said
saying in other words if a
three-year-old boy says I'm a girl my
gosh he's three years old that doesn't
mean anything
it's dangerous to take that seriously
sadly yet predictably Lopez of course
has since issued a groveling apology for
saying something that any sane person
ought to recognize as completely
unavoidable unavoidably unassailably
true under pressure from the radical
left-wing smear machines like the Human
Rights Campaign the media in fact the
the media headlines that you probably
saw earlier in the week about this they
all the headlines were along the lines
of Mario Lopez comes out against
supporting trans kids just so
disingenuous
so Lopez folded like a cheap lawn chair
and disavowed his comments calling them
ignorant and hurtful we'll get back to
his apology in a minute but first
because it's apparently necessary to
clarify this we should establish that
the truth first of all may indeed be
hurtful to people who are grasping
desperately to a delusion so it may it
may hurt them in a way
it may hurt in the same way that you
know getting a shot or something at the
doctor hurts or you know it's but it's
something that they need but there are
certainly nothing remotely ignorant
about observing the fact that three year
old children are immature and
neurologically underdeveloped because
they're three year old three years old
what you'll notice as always about the
people that are coming out against Lopez
is that none of them can explain or have
even attempted to explain why his
comments were wrong
I've read several outraged articles
including the one I mentioned in NBC
News say oh he's so terrible for saying
nose
none of those articles are explaining
okay what what part of it was wrong
exactly and in what way was it wrong so
just tell me how it's gonna hurt
someone's feelings if they read it well
I don't care about that that's not that
because that doesn't have any bearing on
whether or not it's true so in what way
was it untrue even Lopez himself in his
maiya culpa didn't go into specifics
about what part of this statement was
incorrect um you know if he's gonna come
out now and say oh you know never mind I
was wrong about that well what new
information did he stumble across in the
last few days that made him realize oh
you know what actually children can
choose their own gender well of course
there's no there's no new information
the left has no coherent reasons or
rational defenses when it comes to this
issue and so many other issues as well
they have only ideology and they have
emotion which all signify nothing here's
the reality a three-year-old child
cannot reliably make any choice in any
context I'm not exaggerating I've had
three three-year-olds in my house they
can't make choices you take a
three-year-old to baskin-robbins you ask
him which flavour he prefers and he's
going to give you 14 different answers
before he collapses into tears he
literally can't decide
you let a three-year-old decide what
outfit he's gonna wear for the day and
he's gonna come from his room with one
shoe no pants a diaper on his head he
just he has no idea
you let a three-year-old decide let him
go into the kitchen choose anything he
wants for dinner what he's gonna end up
with is a bowl full of ketchup with a
side of gunny gummy bears covered in
whipped cream because a child at that
age has not developed which doesn't
sound like a bad dinner actually but all
the same a child at that age has not
developed a cognitive ability to assess
a variety of options and decide the
correct course the safest course the
healthiest course the most sensible
course children
can't do that and they're not gonna have
that ability for several more years and
if a child grows up to be a leftist
they're never going to develop that
ability so you certainly can't expect
three or three-year-olds to have that
availability now of course when we're
talking about this we should stipulate
that nobody can choose his or her own
gender so when I say someone at 3 or 3
years old can't do it well yes but
nobody can do it so it's not like I'm
saying that once you get older maybe you
can't no nobody can do it because that
matter is irrevocably settled by our
chromosomes and our reproductive organs
and that's it
but the leftist position on this topic
is so preposterous so absurd that even
if you grant them the premise that
gender can theoretically be chosen even
if I were to say okay sure you can
theoretically you could choose your own
gender I'm not granting that but let's
just say for the sake of argument I did
they would still be wrong for thinking
that someone at 3 years old can choose
it so even if it was possible to choose
your own gender it would still be the
case that of course you can't at 3 years
old there's a reason why toddlers are
not entrusted with any legal powers or
responsibilities they can't drive they
can't vote they can't take out a
mortgage they can't buy a gun they can't
buy a ticket for an r-rated movie they
can't buy alcohol they can't buy
cigarettes they can't buy anything
because they're simply too young to do
so and we all realize that young
children this is important to realize
about young kids they cannot grasp the
distinction between fantasy and reality
they can't grasp it they don't know the
difference if you tell a toddler that
Batman isn't real he's gonna stare at
you blankly because the term isn't real
doesn't mean anything to him he doesn't
know what do you mean isn't real it's
that is a phrase empty of meaning for a
young child my I remember my oldest son
maybe I've told this before
my oldest son about about 4 years old
he's 6 now I once caught him on the
second
of our house nearly about to leap over
the banister on the balcony to the you
know to plunge 15 feet to the first look
now I stopped him just in time and I
warned him very sternly you cannot do
that you can't do it you'll go to the
hospital you might die if you do that
you can't do it but he explained to me
that well but what spider-man does that
stuff all the time spider-man does it
I've seen spider-man and jump over down
off of the entire buildings and I
explained to him I tried to explain to
him look spider-man isn't real okay he's
not real that's not a real thing that
people can do and then he said to me no
you're wrong daddy I've seen him on TV
and I realized that it's just there's no
so that I had to say okay yes spider-man
can do it but you're not spider-man
though okay so that's why the whole
concept of spider-man not being real
didn't mean anything to him I was at the
lake with my with our current three or
well he's about to be three years old
and we were at the lake a few weeks ago
and I was gonna put him in his life
jacket so he could go in the water and
he was insisting to me that he doesn't
need to wear life check and I said you
you do need a life jacket it's not safe
and he said but I'm a fish daddy but you
know what I did even though he told me
he was a fish here's the crazy thing
this is how oppressive I am as a parent
I still made him wear the lifejacket I
said okay Nemo but you still gotta wear
the life jacket isn't that crazy
as he didn't want to he insisted he was
a fish but as a parent I knew that
wasn't true and so I forced him to do
the safe and sensible thing as a parent
yes I think that is what we're supposed
to do are we supposed to believe that
people kids who are this ignorant and
immature innocently detached from
reality they have an excuse to be
ignorant I mean literally ignorant as in
they they lack information that's what
ignorant means are we supposed to
believe that they can make meaningful
declarations about their own gender a
boy who says he's a girl doesn't even
know what
girl is that's that's the thing
now adult leftist they don't know what a
girl is either and I've talked about
this many times on the show I've put
this challenge out to adult leftist say
can you define the word woman they can't
do it and you defeat the entire
transgender argument as I've explained
with that question it's done you've
defeated it just ask them next time
someone tells you about this oh transit
just say what's a woman to find him
they can't you win they lose it's as
simple as that but children especially
can't define these terms they don't know
what it means so when I you know if if
you're if you're tempted to take a
three-year-old seriously three-year-old
boy seriously when it comes as I'm a
girl if you're tempted at all to take
that seriously before you go and buy
them dresses and start scheduling the
hormone treatments maybe just ask a
simple follow-up question and that
question is okay little Johnny what's a
girl real simple how is it that all
these parents are saying I have a
transgender kid how is it you've never
asked that question to them have you
ever asked them what they mean by that
it's amazing to me that parents could be
this stupid that you would never ask
that question
because if you ask that question I
guarantee you what you're gonna hear in
the answer is something along the lines
of well he's seen his sister playing
with the dollhouse and he wants to play
with the dollhouse - because he thinks
it looks cool what he's really saying is
he is interested in the things that he
in his little toddler brain associates
with girls he is interested in girl
associated things which is fine if he
wants to play the dollhouse let him play
with it doesn't mean he is a girl as
adults it is our job to help children
sort through sort through these things
to help them understand what they really
mean yes that's what we're supposed to
do because they don't know what they
mean they don't know anything about
anything it's up to us to tell them but
Lopes as I said so he apologized
let me read his apology he said the
comments I made were ignorant and
insensitive
and I now have a deeper understanding of
how hurtful they were I have been and
always will be an ardent supporter of
the LGBTQ community and I'm going to use
this opportunity to better educate
myself moving forward I will be more
informed and thoughtful more informed
more informed he said three-year-olds
can't choose their own gender and that
means he needs to be more informed no as
I said all the people Mario who are
coming after you did any of them present
you with information you didn't have
before what's the new information you
say why I lacked information okay well
what what information did you stumble
upon that made you realize oh never mind
actually they can choose their own
gender uh what you see here from Mario
Lopez I don't mean to pick on him
because he's just a c-list celebrity in
Hollywood what I don't even know what he
does now game show host or something so
what do you expect it's it's it's not
like I put all my hopes and dreams on
Mario Lopez fighting the good fight here
but still it bears pointing out that
what we're seeing here that this is just
enormous craven cowardice cowardice on
an almost inconceivable level or it
would be inconceivable if it weren't so
if we weren't so accustomed to seeing it
and it goes to show again because I'll
think about the cowardice here you are
because some people were mad you are now
denying biological reality you are
pretending to not understand reality it
would be no different it's exactly the
same thing as if is if Mario Lopez had
said two plus two equals four and then a
bunch of mathematic relativists got
angry about it and he said you know what
I was ignorant on me to say that it was
thoughtless was hurtful there are many
children all throughout the country who
when they are doing mathematics test
they'll say two plus two equals six or
eight and so I was wrong to insist that
it equals four it's the same thing
there's no
difference if the between that and Mario
Lopez pretending that you know he
doesn't understand arithmetic so this is
where we are and it goes to show again
that our country will be dragged finally
and irrevocably into utter madness into
utter lunacy we will be dragged into the
dark to wallow there forever if the sane
among us do not have even the slightest
bit of courage that's that's the most
important thing in our culture today the
first is the ability to recognize basic
truth because that's what we're down to
now is we are fighting over the most
basic and fundamental truths and these
are the most important there are still
some conservatives who say as a sideshow
issue this doesn't matter this is basic
elemental truth this is just about basic
reality how can we say reality doesn't
matter we didn't give up reality what do
you need that for no this is this is
this is a starting point we need to have
this or there's no hope and arguing
about anything else but aside from
having the ability to recognize truth
the second important thing for us to
have is a little bit of courage don't
need much just enough courage to say for
instance listen I you're upset about it
but boys are boys girls are girls I'm
sorry that's just the reality enough
courage to say that there's a crisis of
courage unfortunately among these same
people and that's why we're giving up
reality and and who knows what kind of
you know world my kids are gonna grow up
in alright speaking of giving up on
reality CNN ran an article yesterday
with with this title and this is not a
joke this is real the title is robot
racism yes says a study showing humans
biases extend to robots now the
researchers in the study and I I swear
to I know this is a cliche at this point
but when I saw that headline
i reaiiy at first I really thought it
was the onion I really did I thought it
was a joke it's not the researchers in
the study make the point that most of
the robots you see are white and if you
ever if you watched one of those clips
of the robots being unveiled in Japan or
whatever and and you know usually
they're white right as in they're
painted white and this is racism you see
so let me read of a few very real
sentences from this very real article an
article that does in fact exist in the
actual real world and even when you read
the article you if you didn't see CNN at
the top you would still think well this
is a parody this is satire it's not so
the article says in part robots and
racism a study conducted by the human
interface Technology Laboratory in New
Zealand and published by the country's
University of Canterbury suggests that
people perceive physically human-like
robots to have a race and therefore
apply racial stereotypes to white and
black robots these colors have been
found to trigger social cues that
determine how humans react to and behave
toward other people and also apparently
robots
Kristof bartnick explained that the bias
against black robots is a result of bias
against african-americans oh yeah the
bias against black robots he really said
that with a straight face it's amazing
it good continuing it's amazing to see
how people who had no prior interactions
with robots
show racial bias towards robots the
researchers think this is an issue that
needs to be addressed if robots are
supposed to function as teachers friends
or carers for instance then it'll be a
serious problem if all of these roles
are only ever occupied by robots that
are racialized as white all right first
of all what you see here again is well
the first thing we could say here is
this is just amazingly stupid even by
the already very stupid standards of our
society this is incredibly fantastic
stupid the second things you find this
projection a lot these days where this
person is saying oh these robots are
racialized as white and they know that's
you are doing that the rest of us aren't
I I have never in my life even
contemplated the race of a robot or ever
thought of it in those terms and if
you're telling me that we okay so a
white robot has been racialized as white
then what I mean this this white piece
of paper is this is this a myrational
izing this as a white person someone
made the point yesterday I forget who on
Twitter that you know toilets are white
so what's the say is that is that and
what a robots do they serve humans
robots are slaves to humans essentially
so what does that mean it means if most
robots were black what would these
researchers be saying they would say oh
it's racist because black people you
know black robots harken back to slavery
people are painting their robots black
and that shows that they're they have an
innate desire to enslave black people or
something you know that's what they
would say you know it it is racist if
you do racist if you don't this is one
of the most perfect examples of that in
action all right um let's see what else
here here's a story that I've had in the
doc for a few days I'm gonna use the
word shocking and I think that it is
with it I could say that without
hyperbole I think it is a shocking story
this is from the from the MIT Technology
Review and the headline is scientists
are making human monkey hybrids in China
so let me let me just read a little bit
of this to you it says a controversial
first a team of researchers have been
creating embryos that are part human and
part monkey according to a report from
the Spanish daily el pais according to
the newspaper the Spanish born biologist
Juan Carlos who operates a lab at the
Salk Institute in California has been
working with
monkey researchers in China to perform
the disturbing research the objective is
to create human animal cámaras in this
case monkey embryos to which human cells
are added the idea behind the research
is to fashion animals that possess
organs like a kidney or liver made up
entirely of human cells such animals
could be used as sources of organs for
transplantation and then it goes on for
this of course this kind of research is
banned in the in the United States but
it's not banned in China which is why
they're doing it there in China I think
what you find here now it's ostensibly
they're doing this because as it said
they're I guess they're looking to
create animals that can be harvested for
their organs if you could grow human
organs inside animals but what you find
here again and this is the problem with
stem-cell research with IVF with all
these things that we do with humans at
the embryonic level it's what you find
it's the it's the commodification of the
human person where we look at people as
commodities and that's why you find it
you know IVF labs you have a bunch of
leftover embryos just you throw them in
the freezer like it's leftover chicken
or something you just put it in there
and this is a this is a big problem when
we start to see look you're either going
to see human beings as sacred as beings
of infinite almost mystical value you're
going to see them that way or you're
going to see them as commodities as
things that can be used and experimented
on and and stored in freezers and so on
I think those are the only two ways to
see the perks see a person it is sort of
a that's the dichotomy if you go with
the latter option and you see them as
commodities it's not hard to see where
it leads it's not hard to see this lip
three slope if human beings are
commodities at the embryonic level then
you know you just keep going further and
further down the stage of development
and you start to see people in general
that way so this is a very concerning
development all right we're gonna do
some some emails which I haven't had a
chance to do the last few days Matt well
show at gmail.com Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com is an email address let's see
here it says this is from Cassandra says
hello mr. Walsh it is my son's
fourteenth birthday today and both my
boys enjoy your podcast
my older son actually requires us to
pick up the candles to blow them out
after your birthday cake episode could
you wish my son Derek happy birthday
he'd like that
happy birthday Derek and so Derek is not
your oldest son then I guess based on
that but I would urge Derek that we did
talk about this when you blow out the
birthday candles Derek make sure to pick
up the candle pick it out out of the
cake and blow it - you don't want to
because you don't want to blow your
germs and your mucus all over the cake
you know the cake does not I know it's
your birthday the cake does not need a
covering of Derek mucus it doesn't need
it that's a this is why I don't need
birthday cake it's very traumatizing for
germaphobes like myself at every
birthday when you see someone blowing in
what now I'm gonna get off now I'm gonna
go on a whole thing of this and what
other context would you ever eat food
that someone else has blown on like if
the if the waitress was bringing you a
steak and said adds a little hole it's a
little hot hold on sorry and started
blowing on it and then gave it to you
would you eat it
no stop blowing on your cakes people
don't tell me it's a tradition okay
there are a lot of things that have been
traditions in human society but we
develop we become civilized people used
to go out and and you know and and use
the bathroom in a hole in the ground in
the backyard or in a pot which they
would then dump into the street okay we
don't do that anymore
happy birthday Derek
is from Kyle says Matt of colossal
intelligence I'm not sure if I have to
subscribe to email you but I recently
saw this on an Instagram story and could
not believe what I was seeing this is
she has an attachment and it's a meme
that says if you go on a mission trip to
see the kids in Mexico but support a man
whose goal is to put these kids and
their families in cages because they
were fleeing the same poverty violence
you're trying to help then you didn't go
on a mission you went for a photo op
that's the that's the the memes that
Kyle here is referring to okay back to
colleges I believe this is wrong on
multiple levels namely the view of
missions that is presented here in the
political view I know that you support
missions wholeheartedly according to
this if you go on a mission trip it's
just for a photo-op I could go on for a
while about this but I will spare you a
lengthy email and I will let your
supreme colossal intelligence handle
this I feel like I should say something
but I would like to hear your take on
this as well love listening to your show
while I'm at work thanks what you do
yeah obviously I disagree the the point
this meme is trying to make is I guess
if you support now they talk about kids
in cages but what they're really saying
is if you support enforcing our borders
and if you support enforcing immigration
law then you're somehow a hypocrite for
going on mission trips that obviously is
ridiculous so that's point one point two
however I do think that it is sometimes
the case that people go on mission trips
as a photo-op
that anyone who's been on a mission trip
I think they they won't deny this not
that you'd be the case for them
personally but they've seen it this is
something that use these people there
are people who want to go on the mission
trip because they want to get the
pictures for Facebook and they go down
there to wherever it is you know
wherever they're going and they don't
really do much they swing a hammer they
pose for pictures for Instagram and
that's pretty much it
and I do think that's that can be a
problem so I think there are a lot of
people who go on mission trips because
they have a real passion for helping
people and then there are a lot of
people who go because it's it's a trip
it's almost like vacation
and I think that that's you know we
should make it clear to people and this
is one this is one thing you know you
see schools and things they go Christian
schools they take or churches they get
together big buses of people to go on
mission trips again it's a good idea I
like it but it's also bad for
Christianity if you have a whole bunch
of people down there who clearly are
only there for the further photos and
that is a problem sometimes but the
point that they're making in the meme of
course is untrue this is from Andrew
says you recently were talking about the
death penalty and I agree 100% with you
but I was talking with my best friend
recently who's a seminarian and he
presented an argument that made me
reconsider my stance on the subject he
basically argued that the person in
prison can find redemption while living
out his sentence the death penalty will
end his chances of finding it in God's
time I got stumped on this so I'm
wondering how you would respond thank
you for all you do and I'm ready to face
my death penalty like a man when you
become dictator well that's that's good
to know
because you will Andrew yeah this is an
argument I hear a lot from from
Christians about the death penalty it's
an argument when I was anti death
penalty it's it wasn't my main argument
against it but it was something that
concerned me here's what I would say to
that especially in our country now we
don't live in a country where we have
summary execution where you're tried
found guilty they take you out back and
shoot you that day that's not how it
works in this country in this country
you've got sometimes decades on death
row in which I think is too long now I
could sometimes see the appeal and the
efficiency of the summary execution
approach but I wouldn't be in favor of
that I think giving people I don't think
we need to give people 20 years I think
that's too long but whatever if a few
years a period of time a length of time
when they're on death row and if they
have that time which again people in
this country do then that's I think
that's a lot of time not only to get
right with God as it were but you're on
death row you're facing your own death
you are every day facing your own
mortality and so I guess my feeling is
if that's not gonna be enough to drive
you to repentance if that's not enough
you know if spending five years on death
row with death writing the name you're
literally in a row in prison waiting to
be killed if that's not going to be
enough to bring you to repentance to
bring about some kind of spiritual
awakening then you know I I don't think
30 years or 40 years just wallowing in a
prison cell will do it I mean you you
can make the argument that as far as
giving people a chance to repent maybe
the death penalty's is better for that
because it does cause people to confront
their own mortality and it still gives
them time to repent this is from
Stephanie says hey Matt Big Finish oh
you're mixed between dry humor and
profound thoughts is really refreshing
and fun to listen to I'm a young
Catholic woman in my mid-20s all around
me I see all these beautiful young women
with equally beautiful personalities and
faith lives were inexplicably single
where I see on one hand a surplus of
fantastic single Catholic women being
called to the vocation of marriage and
motherhood on the other I see a lack of
good Catholic single men most of the
ones I know lift crazy sinful lived
crazy sinful lives and are now prowling
for a good Catholic woman but not
because they had a conversion of faith
but because they've had their fill of
the hookup phase and just want a good
woman to check a box for nuclear family
it's repulsive and frankly insulting and
discouraging that this seems to be
what's left for single Catholic women
who strive for a rich relationship to
God with God but we're not lucky enough
to meet their spouse earlier in life my
question is do you have any advice for
these women and when you are supreme
dictator can you implement laws that
force young men to stop act stop acting
so pathetic and selfish because while a
guy can get married and have kids
whenever he wants us women have an
expiration date on our eggs and we can't
wait forever for y'all to grow up you
know
Steffie is interesting because I get
this type of question from young
Christian guys all the time in the
Reverse wondering where all the good
Christian women are so it seems like you
got
looking for each other but your your
your signals getting crossed here
your Europe you're both getting lost
amid the fog of modern culture and amid
a fog that is immediately filled with a
lot of prospects that are not very
promising you know dating scene but on
but in in mid that crowd there are
people men and women's that are sort of
looking for each other so what I would
say is and I'm not saying you're doing
this but I do want to mention that you
shouldn't hold you mentioned you said
guys who lived crazy sinful lives and
you said lived past tense I think it is
important that you shouldn't hold
someone's past against them there are
plenty of people who lived crazy sinful
lives as you say and are now trying to
put that behind them and trying to be
different so I would say don't judge a
man by his past I mean there are
exceptions right but yeah David's if
there's something really dark and
terrible in their past and then maybe I
would stake it steer clear that but but
for the most part especially when it
comes to these things and unfortunately
in our culture just sort of
run-of-the-mill you know if there's a
guy who sort of acted like a normal 20
year old guy when he was 20 it's not an
excuse but if he's now 25 or 30 then
he's grown up and he's moved past that
then I would let him move past it I
think this goes into something I wanted
to talk about probably still will maybe
next week haven't had the time yet and
that's about the guy who wrote the why I
kiss dating goodbye book back in the 90s
who was a Christian pastor but he has
sense and I didn't realize that this
until this week but he long ago here
announced that book and apologized for
it
and most recently this past week he
announced that he's not actually
Christian anymore and he's getting
divorced from his wife which it's a sad
situation and that's all aside from the
point here but there is a conversation
to be had about the idea of Christian
purity I think on one hand it's it's
good to strive for purity obviously and
much of what's in that book which I
haven't read but I I know the gist of it
from what I understand of that book I
agree with with much of it but I do
think the cons
of Christian purity can have negative
side-effects and one of those side
effects is the idea that a person who
has a past a person who has committed
sins is now somehow stained somehow
defective somehow ruined by it like the
can move past it like they can never be
a good Christian and I worry that people
believe that about themselves and that
maybe some Christians on the dating
scene believe it about others on the
dating scene or maybe they look at a guy
and they say oh no look at it you know
you see his past look at his look at the
way he used to live he's damaged goods
now I think we're sort of conscious of
that problem with with women where are
we you know where a woman can feel that
way about herself wrongly that she's
somehow damaged goods because of her
past guys can feel that way too about
themselves Christian guys so I would say
watch out for that and as for actually
finding the good men out there all I can
say and this one's not gonna be very
helpful but all I can say is be decisive
and direct and open about what you want
what you want you're looking for a
serious relationship one that might be
headed somewhere to marriage
maybe right ultimately in good time so
be open about that and I think if you're
open about that fact
you're gonna automatically weed out most
of the bad apples because the bad apples
are not interested in commitment minded
women if you fight a Christian guy
whatever it was in his past doesn't
matter if you find a Christian guy who
appears now to be a decent guy
and he's looking and your commitment
minded and he knows that about you and
he's still interested then that's he's
probably that's that's good that's he's
probably a good guy
regardless of what he might have done in
the past so that's what I would say to
that thank you for the the emails and
remember Matt well show at gmail.com for
any other emails and we'll leave it
there have a great weekend everybody
Godspeed if you prefer facts over
feelings if you aren't offended by the
brutal truth if you can still laugh at
the nuttiness filling our national news
cycle well tune on in to the Ben Shapiro
show where you'll get a whole lot of
that and much more we'll see you there